there is no business online that would
not benefit from using a database
whether you are running a small startup
or a billion dollar company not only are
they most common and efficient way of
storing data but they also form the
foundation of business intelligence and
information management today and if you
want to communicate with these databases
you must learn SQL SQL are often
referred to as SQL by many as considered
as one of the oldest languages in
technology domain which is used to
design build and maintain database
applications tailored to specific needs
of the client's business requirements
some popular and widely used SQL
databases are MySQL Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database and postgresql SQL
developers are high in demand with
companies like Microsoft cognizant meta
Accenture IBM entity data and many other
Tech genes hiring SQL developers with an
average salary of seventy two thousand
dollars and going as high as hundred and
thousand dollars per year SQL is
unquestionably one of the first steps
towards a career involving data
crunching and learning it will add Great
Value to your array of skills which
requires little to almost no coding
knowledge will SQL ever be replaced
anytime soon well probably not SQL is
here to stay and will continue to be the
go to query language for many years to
come that's SQL wrapped up in two
minutes